dans la cour d'un institut reconverti en
caserne par des volontaires de la
défense nationale de la grande visite
chacun veut prendre une photo avec
collègues script comme une vedette du
rock nationale venus les soutenir
ils entonnent de vieilles chansons à la
gloire de l'ukraine comme il le fait
presque chaque jour auprès des
combattants c'est sa contribution à
l'effort de guerre gonfler le moral des
troupes c'est mon arme c'est les
guitares c'est la voix c'est les paroles
c'est la chanson c'est l'accordéon les
cardio et en plus
les artistes il sonné pour pour sentir
les tendances de l'atmosphère
moi depuis depuis vingt ans vingt cinq
ans je chante les chansons militaire
andré yves nuke a plutôt choisi lui de
prendre les armes immensément populaire
auprès des jeunes il est maintenant
engagée dans une unité de combat de la
police il n'a jamais songé à quitter la
ville
je suis ukrainien et l'ukraine et mon
pays dit-il je vise ici c'est ma ville
comment pourrais-je l'abandonner
au tout début de l'invasion lors d'une
patrouille il a chanté un vieux chants
patriotiques
la vidéo est devenue virale
événements du groupe pink floyd a été
tellement touché qu'il a décidé de
reprendre sa guitare
la chanson here i rise up est devenue un
hymne de la résistance ukrainienne et
les fonds recueillis seront versés à des
oeuvres humanitaires
mais tout ça est bien loin déjà pour
andrei il a depuis été blessé par un
éclat de mortier et à ceux qui
s'étonnent qu'un artiste comme lui
soient prêts à tuer des gens et
il répond que tu es s'applique à des
humains qui si on détruit ceux qui
veulent vous tuer ceux qui bombarde vos
enfants qu'ils ne respectent pas les
droits de la personne et les règles de
droit international
de son côté oleg à entonner une dernière
chance au plus grand plaisir de ses
volontaires qui sont des civils et qui
chante avec
ça leur permet d'oublier un moment les
horreurs de cette guerre que la plupart
d'entre eux le 24 février dernier ne
pouvait même pas imaginer cette guerre
[Musique]
très dures et le 24 le ventre à levante
4 90% des ukrainiens on croyait pas que
ça peut arriver comme ça quand je pense
que c'est complètement délirant délai
revenir dans le style de moya maj
envahir avec les chats un grand piste et
16 mai avant de retourner à son unité
andrei tiens à remercier le canada qui
lui a fourni une partie son équipement
le gilet pare balle lui a d'ailleurs
sauvé la vie et il a un dernier message
son unité a aussi besoin d'équipements
de vision nocturne la guerre est loin
d'être terminée céline galipeau radio
canada qui est